and he beat um they were rocky 2-zip
and and it was against the king so maybe
this is
you seeing something i don't know all
right here we go ladies and grand finals
here saudi arabia versus georgia and you
know it's
if he was gonna try a different
character now now is the right time when
you have a cushion of being in the
winner's side of the ground finals right
but talking about a cushion and it seems
like um
nina needs a cushion because she's
getting beaten up on
north
and yeah down four okay and you know do
you know why i don't agree with this
like okay maybe you feel like uh this is
a better matchup for you but the risk
he's taking giving rafe any bit of
momentum is a very scary thing to do
well it really looks like he's he's
starting like he needs business
oh no
yeah was is this gonna come back to bite
him in the booty
bite him in the booty oh gosh
he's just okay nice he's gotta stop
doing that bro
he's going to get to the wall of course
he's going to get to all kingdom that is
a very nice conversion i'm not sure
about the wall combo after and wow kind
of amounted to nothing there so ray
already on the train
he's he's looking unstoppable but like
he said this isn't all james's um main
character he's probably maybe using this
as
a tester but it
may not be a good idea mate look at this
domination right now from a rape he's
just rushing him down bulldogging not
letting him get anything started he's in
the corner right now so this is an
opportunity for ultra interpreter he has
rage available as well but rafe
they can't hit trade
okay now she uses the rage
no great
what's it okay here
that was the worst need to be very
careful and up forward to we've seen
this so much we've seen him
put this move out and be very successful
with it it does have evasive um
properties a little sidestep there and
that look comfortable um all right
ladies and lads uh the grand finals
hasn't started yet it's gonna start now
okay so we're hoping
we're guessing that we're gonna get a
king pick from ultra superstar because
that didn't work but again um if he had
an idea of maybe this can work versus
gin because again both complain and uh
potato have had a bit a long opportunity
to watch grace play in losers so they're
trying to scout him out whichever way
possible
he's tried after nina he's in winner's
side of the grandfather which means
ladies and gents that rife has to win
two first two threes and uh a potato
only needs to win one so for him you
know this is a if he wants to try out a
new character now was his only chance
really you don't want to mess around now
don't stand back don't try anything new
go with what's been working if it ain't
broke don't fix it and see if you can
take this guy out yeah um
this is scary because now he's already
given him that momentum he's got him
started and
these characters like gin it's not
conventional downfall two inputs it's
it's you know you have to warm up their
fingers or stick with the wrists and
he's warm
this guy's ready for the next battle as
the game just said he is ready
um i'm thinking he's going to be king i
i if i see a nina on the screen again
it's going to be yeah it had to be king
you had to go back hopefully he used
that one game
to
download whatever information needed to
download um yeah i mean i don't i don't
think that there was any no downloading
going on there i was trying to be nice
back yeah yeah
it was such a professional it was just a
beat down let's be honest and no
information was
was gathered now we're going to start
with our grand finals but it's 1-0 right
now
in this first set first to three ladies
and gentlemen going to the brimstone on
fire let's go okay nice okay this is
what i was talking about getting those
when i'm getting those blocks on the
health sleep really you know making him
doubt when to use them like he gets the
wall bounce
yeah
and that's one of those strings as well
man like it's it's got a high option in
the middle right so yeah probably tried
to duck there and oh my god
oh he wanted to end it now but gets the
whiff punished for the back one two and
already he's looking at uh
very much so
comfortable now a lot more comfortable
okay
nice so that rave is not asleep at the
will at all he's ready for the punish
there we go against the big boy combo
he opt into play i think one reason why
he might be going for down back to
string instead is because he if if you
don't go for the flip flop it allows
them to tech roll and potentially get
themselves out of the wall all right so
maybe just like to keep him at the wall
there oh yeah definitely keeping someone
at the wall with that pressure um the
way he's playing is is optimal man
if we go to the wall bam bam what a
combo bro what the hell brave lovely
lovely stuff like this guys and he knows
like the degrees and curves of these
walls what the hell man got his protect
protractor
shout out to secondary school yeah the
master
yeah okay
i haven't bought anything from there
since after secondary school bro i'm
surprised that's that shop's still
around you know like it's been ages
well i guess you know i've got people
going to school all the time now but
talking about going to school
going to take him to the wall
too cool for school
oh boy oh boy oh man no oh the combo
video
oh i'm not punished
i did it again cheeky devil oh my gosh
and that just shows that in that ultra
instant potatoes probably rocks and just
just fell asleep at the wheel there
yeah there we go we're gonna get to the
wall uh big boy combo that only works
some bigs on i'm sure i just wakes up
giant swing but rave is ready he's got
the momentum
yeah definitely he's in the zone right
now man talking about ultra instinct i
mean right now right if it's in ultra
instinct the heavy guy can you get
something started nice throughout those
really nice conversions gonna get no he
doesn't get the guarantee the temper
what oh kazemi right there now this
could potentially be it
people's
beautiful there clutching it out using
the rage drive for the plush frames and
finishing it with the low this wow guy
is
i i don't know he's
he's playing out of his mind right now
he's
he's found another level he's on another
level in a minute like yeah i cannot see
how he can be stopped it just seems like
no one can stop him at this minute it
just seems like everything's aligned for
him the stars the moon everything it's
just it's there for him man
yeah my man did a waldo before he
started bro he washed his hands his face
everything man he's ready he did his
door before the tournament bro this guy
is he's he's he's asking for a lot to
save him here man and get him that reset
grand finals can he do it i mean look uh
that first ma i said that you know it's
fine to try a new character but
against rife when you see the way he's
playing
it's just like you don't want to give
this man any momentum if that was the
first match
then it's fine the second match you can
try and make it make a comeback but now
is it too little too late obviously is
it too late i really hope not and now
that you're saying that i know this is
just me speaking in hindsight maybe it
would be best for him to start with king
and then if it went to the bracket reset
then try a new character on that one
as you you tried your main and it hasn't
worked so maybe try to switch you up
then but
i'm not in the driver's seat i don't
know this is why i'm here so
so is he gonna go to the uh to the
forgotten realm now are we gonna get
some opportunities for big boy damage
with the kings we actually haven't seen
it much from
from uh potato no he's going to choose
to go for the howard estate
yeah yeah yeah both these stages can net
some pretty big damage for king um but
he now needs to think about you know um
the next the next first of three i know
you shouldn't be thinking about giving
up just use this time now to just play
and try to download as much information
as possible it is 2-0 um
rife only needs one more match to reset
the bracket but i mean if anyone can get
can make this comeback it is ultra
inspiratory as we say just starts off
with the health suite he is definitely
okay no
gets punished there
again oh my gosh dude he's
he's in all drinks with potato's head
this is going to be seven golden letters
what a statement you want to see what
you want to see what momentum looks like
ladies now this is the perfect example
the man is in the zone he ran a massive
gauntlet in the loser side after losing
to luffy he managed to make his comeback
against luffy got the run back beat
complain moved to grand finals and he is
so close to resetting this bracket
he's all over australian
it's like you know he's not getting a
chance to get anything slightly even
blocked loaded and even get like a
punishment okay nice to get something
started now
yeah
come back okay guess it's correctly not
big damage damage
okay
nice
[Laughter]
oh nice
nice
again all chances potatoes the eaters
went also
and all of a sudden he's two to one up
he just got out the uh the hyperbolic
time chamber he just got training he
did some homework and here we go now all
trains are potatoes with the momentum
nice that was a quick turnaround that's
another world record an unofficial world
record there has broken the quickest
turn around
nice all right
going to break it yes
oh my god [ __ ] combo huge damage
yes nice
and just like that
like in in the blink of an eye i would
say because we blinked our eyes and
you just free one up
[Music]
i feel like i feel like we just went to
an alternate universe that was messed up
i was tripping bro i was like what's
going on like well we just went to an
alternate universe all of a sudden it's
like oh wait we're commentating imagine
it like the momentum all of a sudden
just switch to switch
to potato sun he's like grabbing him
i was like what wait wait we was just in
this combo man and he's playing the
screen as well that's the worst thing
he's done the king point light yeah
i've done this
nice well it looks like
potato has the momentum and managed to
claw it back so the comeback is on bubsy
um yeah those last couple of rounds look
very dominant so like i said if anyone
can do it it is ultra insanity he needs
to compose himself and realize that he
has a cushion still you know he has a
whole a whole first or three left to go
if this one doesn't go well so just try
to um gather as much information as
possible on your opponent on his timing
and see what you can do definitely
definitely um
he's definitely slowed down ray like i
said late rafe is a
definitely a very momentum blaze bass
player and um
yeah so breaking the momentum is what he
is what he needs to do
yeah he's got the first game
his first game sorry and yeah hopefully
that kind of slows him down and gives a
multi-engine potato a little bit more
confidence in what he's gonna do
what he needs to do
what changes and adjustments he needs to
make and like as i said he's got a
little bit of a cushion also so he needs
to be using this to download but
what you don't want to do
is put all your cards on the table
because if he does this puts all these
cards on the table it doesn't like work
in his favor
it could be another wraith
right momentum based train and
i don't know it's hard to stop him it's
been very that's what i'm talking about
man but here we go let's get back into
it so a bit of breaking the momentum
there from rife but he's in the loser
side still one match away only one match
is needed to take it to a fresh first of
three and he has started off really
strong hip obviously yes definitely
okay fourth four
trying to net a big car hit the nice
duck use it to 24 for a punish yeah okay
but again he's just rapist is not
letting up just pure relentless pitbull
in there
yeah he's making all the right reads as
well using that sidestep punch every
time he knows potato is going to try and
challenge him hop knee right to the jaw
something like somebody just have to do
it sometimes you have to just put it out
there
you know just make them have something
to think about that's going to be a
punishment oh that is so unfortunate for
potato a massive risk taken
big boy combo there gets the demon port
as well
to the flip over and you see what i mean
when you go for the flip over okay
sometimes your ba your own back can be
put to the wall
oh that's good
skipping over
taking some of that momentum back from
rafe
you know okay nice gets the punish
should a little parried that though but
uh oh
he does so he mitigates the damage there
and one thing you told me a trick uh
quite a few years ago probably was just
mash one and three to like one three one
two one three and then
just match him it's so easy that's bad
thick
people down
you know what when that happens to me i
literally like take both fingers off the
stick and just do one three one three
one two one
never yeah that's literally it yeah
nice
okay go through that low but just
disrespecting the frames and then ultra
instant try to disrespect his frames
i've got caught counter here
oh no it's a reset point now for saudi
arabia rafe here one more round needed
to reset the bracket ultra into potato
guess counter hit yes i can't hit four
so good with gin it goes straight into
tail spin
oh my god he's just running
okay but now nice readjustment
there it let it rip
yep
ford four
okay now he's just backing no rage
available for ultra instant potential as
well his back is to the wall down back
four rage available now what's he gonna
do race can you reset the bracket one
more hit's gonna do it lasers and lads
we have a reset grand finals here
for the tekken online challenge middle
east master event that is saudi versus
georgia and we're going to a final first
to three yola
he's just got the momentum now that's
scary it's it's now i will equal scary
hours now for ultra potato because
it it just looks like even though he he
made a little dent into a wraith it's
just like he just takes it straight back
it's like this guy's unfazed like it's
just like
you do what you want to do but i've got
the answer it's like he just bulldozes
his way his momentum back on top of
yours and just puts you back at square
one it is really scary
i i i genuinely do not know how to stop
this guy it just looks like he has all
the answers and it's
hard when he has that momentum
yeah 100 man look we didn't see the
match that he lost to luffy uh that put
him into the loser bracket but for of
all the matches that we have seen this
man has been dominant dominant dominant
i mean the only match you could say was
against luffy you know in the loser
bracket we saw that match in top a and
it was he needed to make a six round
comeback but he made it he made
six rounds in a row come back against
someone like luffy that is not easy to
do and you can tell that when he has
momentum when he has confidence he just
believes in his reads and they all work
out yeah definitely so right now if
you're all trained to potato bobby what
are you thinking what are you doing if
you're him
i just need to really stop his momentum
and i'm thinking king's not really like
he has pokes but i want to see him as
like a key part just kind of slow down
character i guess he has the down ones
i'm down forward one he has a down one
two i guess but
they're not reliable options to you know
keep
to rely on
and eventually you know
they can get scared out a lot i i just
guess he's got to try and just
maybe offense is the best defense
sometimes but then again i wouldn't
really call class king as a really
offensive character to oppress someone
yeah
i mean you can see that rafe has been
you know doing a really good job in
keeping him out using the jab and then
going in with like hunting him sleep
sending him straight to hell and look at
this he's in the corner now okay ready
like it's bad position unfortunately for
tail and you can't get too predictable
with those giant things right there
because ray did duck but didn't get a
big punish on the dart
it just seems like
ultra insecurity is really uncomfortable
now because he's getting pressing
buttons where he shouldn't be pressing
buttons and
you know and just like this that was a
great example there he had a little bit
of momentum racing nope down one
no more millennium
exactly he's making he's making all the
right reads here to kind of stop
momentum look at that once again the
sidestep punch and a break on the giant
swing so right now he is he's in the
zone bob he's definitely zoning right
now chilling socks off and everything
yeah
okay
how is he gonna break rave i do not know
what to do what can he do as a king
player
he's trying everything he's going for
the plus frames he's going for the
throws he's going for the pokes and
nothing's working right now
these saudi arabians definitely know how
to play against king ladies and gents
one round away from taking the lead in
this set for the first time life from
saudi arabia okay but gets the car here
i'll drink potatoes not out of it just
yet it's gonna get the wall okay just
shy of the wall
and again just has the answers just to
stop
ultra into potato four you're gonna try
and step away from the wall but it just
didn't work
just knew that you know that move with
king you can float if you jab
absolutely oh gosh nice one in two again
what's the combo
nice block i think that may be launched
i'm not sure
because the finish anyway end stops the
three rounds straight no round brown
rafe versus aldrin now if you're all
drinking potato you are panicking heart
palpitations everything anxiety loses
lots of vision you know lots of smell
taste everything hallucinations man he's
seeing armor king now he's like what the
hell is going on this is not why i
picked epic king man like it's looking
it's looking a bit deep right now for
all james patel the momentum that rafe
has if you guys didn't know this man
before this before today now you know
remember the name but bob's it's not
over yet we've seen this many times
you've seen this many times that even
with a lot of momentum and even after
winning the first match in the reset we
have seen composure we've seen tenacity
and we've seen comebacks man yeah this
is um
i said it earlier on scary hours man
this is um a scary time for ultra
instant potato because
we we've seen all tournament that brave
cannot be stopped and it and it seems
like history is repeating himself and
we've said before that so many people
have come back from the losers to win
and you know once i had that momentum
and it just seems like rafe with that
momentum
and it seems like he's growing as a set
grows and he's having more time and it's
just
seems like he's just i don't get it he
just seems like he has the answers so
all she needs to potato for you're gonna
step at this wall i'm gonna use ford
four and he's like no i'm gonna use jabs
now jabs float the homing move for king
it's it's a bit of a double edge homie
if it's a good homing move but it can be
flowing and it just seems like he's just
always like two steps ahead of the game
that's what it seems like
so yeah you said it yourself right after
he got hit by the jabs and then ultra
into potato thought i have some momentum
let me carry this on he got hit by the
dick jam and it's like man every time he
tries to get something started it just
does not work but once again ultron's
but not going for a character switch
he's sticking with the king hair
straightener so i agree i think you
should do you've gone to the howard
estate now um as you can see the
multiple uh wall breaks for some
potential big damage but
here we go we've got to get right to get
them their more breaks in the first
place
such an important match here because we
do not want to see uh potato go down 2-0
uh that might be a little bit too much
for him
super important let's see if potato can
bring it back yeah as you see he's
starting off with a lot of jabs but as i
say that just gets count here and this
is gonna go to the wall
nice realignment there go to the wall
combo
yep
again just using that toe and toe get up
just to
breathe it seems like he just wanted to
get away
oh my goodness hit by again he doesn't
get the combo unfortunately
punished nice again oh my god
hella would
but i like that from ultra instant
potato so he went for the ford four
again at the wall knowing that in the
match previous that lost in the match we
got float with the jab so it shows he's
not deterred he's he's still got his
head on
yeah
okay oh my gosh okay nice conversion
again back against the wall okay nice
we're gonna get some big damage here
okay breaks it
yep one place to your throat take it to
the oh no he doesn't even go for a
tailspin yeah should have probably gone
for the tailspin first and then
oh my god the oneplus 2 throws okay
maybe he found an opening here now bubsy
maybe so maybe definitely need to use
maybe you know you can't break them all
with king okay now scary time
it whiffed but he is a brave man because
we know how rage drives and their
hitboxes go they're very big nice
blocked as a healthy okay
it's like i'm a halal boy man why are
you trying to send me to johanna for nah
no wait get him in the corner here we go
can wrap work his way out
nice see that alternate potato now
taking some of that momentum away but as
i say that just gets can't hit with a
four
four everything just seems to be hitting
everything
he's managed to work his way out that
corner rage available now nice
punishment in the background with a job
here we go now ray back on board isa
seems so scary literally that whole
section everything here
it's how does he have these answers here
we go multiple one out of three guests
okay goes for the sharpshooter this time
bret hart
oh boy
okey dokey
okay needs to be very careful nice
scouts the hell sweet
no he goes for the hard combo and drops
it could could he come back to haunt him
no it's not that's dead no
what is he doing
this is scary time to use the down jab
just to alleviate the pressure oh it was
a float
oh it doesn't get the wall though
oh this is scary
no way no way no you're gonna miss me
there's no way there's no way oh my god
you crazy man
the comeback of the pop off ladies and
gents is it gonna be too overrated what
was that no so he probably thought the
one down three was coming down the one
three three which is the mid
yeah great it just shows rafe is just so
aware and ready he's in the opponent's
head
once again he missed times okay the up
four to the side step punch the instant
break on the giant swing he is playing
so well right now he's in the zone ultra
instincts rafe
he he wave dash into throw break
he's in the zone bro he's he waved oh
that was a car hit bro
oh no
i'll join some potential he's on the
back foot now range available and rafe
ladies and gents it's gonna go up too oh
look at the pop-up as well he's feeling
himself he's in the zone
if there was ever a time for ultra and
super potato to get a match on the board
it was then
but the one pixel comeback bubsy
that was
i i i'm actually speechless the way this
guy
his mind is he's not even two steps
ahead this guy's six steps ahead he
already knows what's gonna happen he's
in the future
like he just knew that okay you're
probably gonna try scout for the one
down three and went for the one three
three which is slow but he was just so
ahead and just knew that in this clutch
situation you're probably looking out
for this you're probably looking out for
the lows and the lower parries to try to
get that momentum back and he just
showed that no i am ahead of you he hits
that mid and he made that comeback
and
like i said that that is when you make
that kind of comeback the momentum shift
and
how it mentally affects you he just
literally snatched that away again and
he is really looking on i don't know
i i think i've said this so many times
he
i don't know how you're going to stop
him he's looking yeah
it's looking rough now but ultron's a
potato has to make a decision now does
he go to infinite does he go to uh the
forgotten realm he needs to do something
different right yeah he's keeping it
close but rafe is his comeback factor
his clutch his mind game he's making
ultra insane potato doubt himself what
we've been seeing all day today and many
tournaments that he's entered we always
see ultra potato making the right
decisions and now rafe is forcing him to
make the wrong decisions by making him
doubt himself with all of his reads so
now rafe you know the mind game is real
the mind game is so so real didn't stop
going for the hell sleep either but
ladies and gents this could potentially
be the final match here if rafe can take
it he worked his way all the way from
the loser bracket early on today
making it through losers run the
gauntlet and now he's one match away
from winning the entire tournament
here we go
definitely last chance saloon he is
locked in with king he has to ride this
all out with king but already he's off
to a bad start
yeah
okay
okay he's at four four two okay
i'm speechless at this minute
yeah he sees the win he can see it man
rape he wants to finish it early not let
potato get any opportunity for a
comeback he got hit by damn back three
and just went for while standing two in
a hit everything this man does is
working everything he touches turns to
gold to maddest touch right is that
right
right
okay okay nice guess i can't hit there
it could be start something from
ultrasound potatoes
oh misses the ground though okay nice
punish
oh that's another account he couldn't
let it rip looks like he's bringing
something back but this is when it gets
scary when ray starts getting momentum
okay all the timing the timing the
timing
okay a ghostly giant and he breaks the
giant swing
yeah this guy's pro-breaking is on point
oh sweet this could be dead he's gonna
go for the rage y'all ladies and lads we
are gonna go to tournament point now
rafe from saudi arabia looking to take
it all this guy
i i i i should leave bro this is crazy
here we go
he's going to take him to the corner and
i'll potentially break the wall
big combo conversion okay this time it's
time to ice kit and get the car here
this is rage is available this is last
chance what is he going to do now this
is last hit oh my god he's not going to
finish it in style rafe is he going to
finish it with a seven golden letters
yola can he finish it right now no break
on the shining wizard okay this is can
this be a comeback for for all things
potato that's our range available no
ladies and lads ray from saudi arabia is
going to be your tekken online challenge
middle east master champion after being
put into losers bracket so early on
running the gauntlet and taking it all
that was an amazing
so we've got our answer no one could
stop him but once he had that momentum
no one could stop him like
wow i don't